orelis l'initié à la conduite de deux
roues sur simulateur elle fait partie
des 50 appelés à participer aux ateliers
de sécurité routière mis en place depuis
le début de l'année 2016 dans le cadre
de la journée de défense et citoyenneté
cette journée constitue la troisième
étape du parcours de citoyenneté
après une sensibilisation en classe à la
défense et un recensement mairie dès
l'âge de 16 ans ça nous a permis aussi
de comprendre le fonctionnement du code
de la route et puis de voir que derrière
derrière notre faim nos vies il y avait
quand même beaucoup de choses face à la
défense j'ai payé ce dispositif de
journée défense et citoyenneté permet
aux jeunes aujourd'hui de bénéficier
d'une explication des enjeux de défense
et de leur rappeler qu'ils ont des
droits et des devoirs en qualité de
citoyen la journée de défense et de
citoyenneté remplace depuis 2011
la journée d'appel de préparation à la
défense elle même institué pour se
substituer au service militaire supprimé
en 1997 par jacques chirac
les deux grands objectifs de cette
journée n'ont quant à elles pas changé
le premier consiste en une explication
des enjeux de défense et puis cette gdc
répond un deuxième objectif
le deuxième objectif consiste en un
volet cohésion sociale puisque la jdc
permet de détecter des jeunes qui soit
en difficulté de lecture ou des jeunes
qui seraient éventuellement en situation
de décrocheurs
cette journée était associé pour
l'occasion à la journée nationale des
réservistes
une journée pour renforcer le lien armée
nation et expliquer l'engagement des
réservistes au quotidien en france
chaque année près de 800 mille jeunes
français accomplissent leur devoir en
participant à la journée de défense et
de citoyenneté
une journée qui pourrait être remaniée à
l'avenir en regard des événements de ces
derniers mois